all right sharp
welcome back thank you for having me
back more so here we are in atlanta
players ball tonight good old atl
players ball
tonight where it is you might get the
10th of the year this year
oh so they saying you probably deserve
it
you probably deserve it what you think
mark do you think i do i think you do i
don't know the game like you know like
some of these guys do but but your
personality certainly deserves something
crazy like that
right well you know in this in this game
you know if you want it for real you got
to do it for real
you know and that's that's just how i
move in my life man i want to do things
for real so you know cause i want real
things in my life man i don't want
nothing fake i don't want nothing phony
you know so i come to what's real this
is my reality
this is my reality man i move around i'm
glad that you came mark this is fun
this one is fun man do you even have to
even have you here
yeah it's fun crap it is man what do you
what's your experiences to it so far
no i mean like you said you've never
been you know involved like that
to know so what is your what's your
experiences here so far what have you
experienced
i mean just a a room full of charismatic
men a few of the
few of the girls are dressed and ready
but right so far it's the afternoon
still it's uh yeah
it's mostly just a bunch of the the
players that are here and uh
they're all they're all interesting
personalities every one of them most
definitely
good friends of mine man they all good
people man good souls
good souls you know it's interesting how
the
you know you can say that the the game
is bad you know for square
you know what you guys do is illegal and
it's bad that's a simplistic view um
but it's interesting interesting how a
lot of the guys
you like them they're really likable
like yourself
they're very likable personalities yeah
and they talk about the lord and they
talk about
you know god and all the other things
they do for the community that are good
so it's a weird an interesting mix of
good and what we what a lot of people
perceive as bad
well you know it's uh i mean it's not
really i mean tell me your take on
i've met a couple of your girls and they
don't complain
they're not unhappy with their situation
you know the last time you were by you
you brought one of your
ladies with and she was bragging about
how much money she's making and how
how great your life is i'll say this man
um i uh
i love i love the game still man i'm not
changing it i'm not
trying to revamp it i'm not trying to i
want it to be as real as this room that
we're in
i wanted to be as real you know and a
lot of people sit there and say oh
he talks a lot of [ __ ] or he runs in
circles hey man
i'm telling you all the truth if you
really listen read between the lines
you know i'm not telling nothing that's
that's phony and if there's anybody that
could take some of my words man and
apply them to their everyday life why
not
what because i am who i am that's the
problem
that's why they don't want to apply it
but deep down inside they go try and
they say [ __ ] man it worked
you know it's okay man some of us are do
have more ambition than others and it's
okay for us to rub some of that off
that is okay there's nothing against the
law
that says that i can't come and give
some people some some news they can use
you know it's been it's been crazy man
it's been a crazy year with kovid you
know and people just
running around acting crazy it ain't
been people like myself running around
acting crazy
it's the people they didn't gave all the
money to that was stealing
it's not us man and this isn't a uh
this isn't a get out of jail free card
or hey you know
look at me i'm a victim i'm not a victim
to anything
i'm not a victim and nor am i trying to
victimize anybody
i'm not trying to make that kind of
impact on anybody's life
i want it to be all positive
you know yes i think a lot of the
confusion with you is your your style of
communication
is kind of indirect but you just
answered the question i asked
but it wasn't like a one-sentence answer
you went here and there and you moved
right runs a million miles an hour man
even when i'm laying there going to
sleep
i'm running my mind a million miles an
hour man i can't stop
thinking thinking is good for this it's
okay to think
it's okay to overthink it's not okay to
under think
you can't do yourself like that man you
got to believe if you
let me ask you this mark if you don't
believe in
you who will
who will believe in you you can't ask
the next door [ __ ] neighbor to
believe in you if he don't see you
believing in yourself
every day it's on us it's all it starts
with you
just like it starts with me just like it
starts with a lot of those other
charismatic people that you said that
you
have had the blessings of encountering
with
they just need to stop knocking the real
man this is very real
real people i'm still a real person i
think just like the next person thinks
mark
i do i don't think i don't i don't think
that i'm i'm out here just trying to
hurt people and go crazy even though
that's everybody's
that's how everybody looks at me that's
everybody's mode is oh he's a [ __ ] up
individual
oh he he's running him down in the
ground he's got him on drugs i don't do
drugs
sorry to bust your bubble drug-free
program up over here
i went to deer it worked for me
and i met one of your girls last time i
think i met two of your girls and and
they were happy and you know had good
things to say about their lives
and uh i didn't i didn't detect any kind
of uh
strangeness going on i don't even know
what you're talking about
good answer i don't but um i don't know
i like i like coming and hanging out
with you man
it's like where i get to come and uh
confess my sins you know or
confess my truth rather what do you
worry about what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear is not being who i
really want to be
or waking up that's why i think i don't
do
that's why no excuse me that's why i
know
i don't do drugs or try to have any type
of serious vices because i've always
been afraid
i've always been yeah me i'm afraid
i've always been afraid of getting up
looking in the mirror and not
recognizing myself
so that's why i've never gotten lost
like that in the sauce
yeah drugs have always been around me i
mean drugs comes i think with anybody's
life hell you could be a politician
and be into drugs heavy so it doesn't
really matter what walk of life
you know it's just about the type of
person that you are
i'm a firm believer in that mark i
really am man i really am
be who you are that's the only thing
that that i'm really afraid of man
it's just i don't want to wake up one
day and not recognize myself
i think believing in yourself as you do
and as i do
um keeps you from ever wanting to
comfort yourself with with with advice
like drugs or alcohol or
gambling or whatever that is you got to
look at your life like you're already
winning
yeah that's why i don't gamble and
people ask me you know i'm going to
casinos all the time you know i see
people gambling or i know
uh you know dealers at tables that'll
see me a lot you know and they'd be like
hey man why don't you come over here and
spend a couple bucks come on man come
win
something and i'll stop and tell them
hey man i'm already winning
and keep pushing i'm already winning i
don't need to come spend my money with
it make me feel like i'm i'm gonna oh
let me go try to win no i'm already
winning i know where the
the sure winnings are did you have you
always recognized as i have
that everyone is doing something
that's usually an indicator that it's
something to to avoid
yeah i saw that early on and i'm like
yeah everyone's doing something i think
they're all wrong
yeah i'm just gonna stand back and and
sure enough every single time they're
always wrong
they're always wrong you always watch
them go to their own failure
they they they create their own failures
man yeah you have to think for yourself
you have to man listen i haven't been
around all types of walks of life
different
different types of entities of people
wanting to do from man companies drug
dealers i don't care what it is i've
been and i've never changed me i've
always been the same person
and they've always loved me or liked me
for who i am
i've never had to change nor to change
my persona or the person that i
am ever it's just the people that hide
behind this camera that start getting in
those funky ass comments that want to
hide
it's not people that i've ever met like
how people say oh i couldn't stand to be
in a room with him for five minutes
you've never been in a room with me for
five minutes and you wouldn't really
know
i mean you turn on your personality into
overdrive on camera but in person you're
a
little more laid back i mean come on you
know you're very i listen when i get on
camera i got a lot to say
it's a lot my mind starts racing so you
know it's hard to let it out man it's
hard to let all this
is on out you know i mean for those that
don't i'll get tongue tied sometimes
for those that are like wondering what
you're all about you're not like this
all the time 24 7. no
yeah no you're turning it on for the
camera a little bit i mean you got a
little bit not a lot
of hey man listen to me this people have
to understand this isn't a character
this is really who i am no absolutely
this is really me when the cameras go
off i still speak the same way maybe
maybe not as firm because when i'm
sitting here in front of this camera man
i don't know who's about to watch this
who's going to see this so you know what
i'm going to speak
firm and i'm going to speak like a man i
have no doubt that
at whatever hour in the morning you wake
up you this is who you are before you
have your coffee
this is who you are man i listen to me
man i'm old school man
structure and balance is everything to
me i still get up and mop my floors i
still do my dishes i still
keep a clean household i was telling a
buddy of mine downstairs i was like you
know
if you wake up in and this is to anybody
right
if you wake up in a shitty environment
shit's thrown
everywhere shit's [ __ ] up the room
smells
how do you think your personality is
going to be
during that day your aura your persona
how do you think it's going to be it's
going to be [ __ ] it's going to be
everything that was in that room
but if you wake up and everything's
clean and everything smells good
don't give a [ __ ] what you're going
through wake up in a clean environment
structure and balance is key
it helps the mental man it really does
no matter what you're going through we
all go
through man people lose their entire
families
[ __ ] it don't wake up in a [ __ ] up
environment because it'll [ __ ] your mind
up you're already dead
might as well go join along
i've missed this this is oh this is the
best right here isn't it
[Laughter]
how many players balls have you been to
oh [ __ ]
man i start going to them and
maybe 05 000 405 and
i ain't stopped yet it's always been my
friends though man i grew up around
a lot of these guys you know i grew up
around him as a kid man so you know
they they they know me i'm not star
struck by any of it they're not star
struck by me we've always all been
friends you're wearing the boys
it's one of the boys man that's it
just one of the boys made part of the
church you did
yeah yeah it's a beautiful thing man
so a lot of people i might that watch my
videos or watch your video
respond to you strongly they say pimp
for president
2024 and all this kind of crazy stuff um
have you always had have you always had
this magnetism
from people just just from people that
meet you or know you or
go to school with or whatever uh no
because i think you know and i'm not
gonna say everybody but you have to
understand more
everybody's trying to get there
themselves they don't want to slow down
for a second and say hey you're the man
makes them feel like [ __ ] that makes any
sense
kind of makes them feel like [ __ ] man to
sit there and say hey you know
everybody's trying to get on
everybody man everybody they ain't gonna
tell me i'm doing right and they not
and they know who it is so that part of
it doesn't even
doesn't even phase me i don't even think
about that nor do i want to
because it comes with ugly things from
people even if you're living in a
you have to think about it man you going
just say you work a regular job you're
the best
of it all of them know you're the best
of it
they rather try to watch you to do
something [ __ ] up to get you fired and
to come say hey mark you did a [ __ ]
outstanding job we know you're the best
here
you think most people want to knock you
down
never but you know what i've never i've
been knocked down
or people have attempted to try to knock
me down
in an outside life more than in this one
there's nothing but love and peace and
harmony in this
from the people that i know do you find
you get that kind of uh
into those kind of conflicts with with
people often your personality is big
oh yeah man i bump into people all the
time but as long as that we got a clear
understanding that i'm me
because you're you here's the line
and i guess this is where we part ways
i'm okay with doing that with people not
everybody's for you not everybody's your
friend
i love watching people run around doing
that [ __ ] oh this is my friend this is
my friend
what have you and your friend really
have have you ever went through
what they would call a traumatic bond
like [ __ ] it it's not always good times
you know what i'm saying
when something really [ __ ] up happens
does that person still stand in your
corner sometimes you go through hell
or do they fold on you
do they hold or do they fold i'm a
person that holds man
at all costs what what what what
rules do you live by or what what things
do you believe
deeply that you live by like for me for
example
it's there's an easy way to do things
and there's a really difficult way to do
things
and what i've learned is there's those
difficult ways of doing things
will bring about the the optimal result
the better result
well and that's what i want so i'm
willing to work as hard as i i
need to well i'm a person that you know
i've always believed in
working smart and not hard i've always
i've always been a firm believer in that
man you know and uh
telling truth to the people that are
around me i listen if you're not doing
what i'm doing
mentally mentally i can't [ __ ] with you
i can't you have to have that you have
to have a mindset on you that's out of
this world
i grew up around old school ways so i
still
obtain those ways that structure that
balance
that is key to me that is that is what
makes sharp run
that's what keeps me moving baby is
being able you know what
people need to stop trying to control
what they can't control and start trying
to control the things they can
that's all i did baby i got smart and i
learned to control the things i can
what do you what do you say to this this
is something else i believe in
fear is a is a guide or a compass of
what
you very much so very much so whenever
you're afraid of something that's
usually
exactly what you should do right i've
listened man
we've all we all got fears we all do no
matter how strong my voice may say hey
man we
all got fears you got fears the viewers
they got fears
but it's about really facing the belly
of the beast
man that's what makes you strong
sometimes
you gotta learn the hard way it makes
you who you are
it's okay to get smacked on the ass
every now and again
and real and you know get a little pinch
to let you know you're alive
and you are living it's okay for any of
us to get that
even including myself it's great for us
it's
healthy for us mentally and physically
all the [ __ ] time you know what i was
thinking right
and i and i really feel this way like
people
get people go watch or people go watch
you know soft white underbelly and they
get on there and
you know they wake up that morning they
might not be feeling the best about
their life so
they go and they oh let me go look at
this person well this person's life's a
little bit more [ __ ] up than mine so i
guess i
you know i don't have to feel as bad you
know
even though these are real these are
people's real lives that you're sitting
there
feeling better on you're feeling better
on their shittiness
and then when you find a person like me
charismatic
standing strong probably eating more
than you
you find a problem with that so then
they start to hate
and then the hatred just grows even
bigger and bigger to where you can't
even put the flame out but the
the hate in a lot of these kind of
situations is envy
it's just envy look at you you're
charismatic you're handsome you're
you're outspoken you're easy to hate for
especially for a male
hey man you know what's so cold though
it's cause i don't hate them no no
i don't hate anything i don't hate
anything about the next man no you
you don't take it as it's not a
competition against it's never been a
competition
when did when were we ever racing i
thought this was a marathon
when were we ever in the [ __ ] amazing
race i didn't i don't understand this
part of it
i don't want to compete with the next
man i'm not trying to sit outside and
have pissing contests with you to see
who the [ __ ] piss the furthest i'm
cool it's hard enough to deal with your
own man i'm good man i'll go use the
toilet
i'll go to the bathroom i'm fine i'll
pass
what's been the hardest thing you've
gone through in your life
not having my kids with me every day
every second
that's that's being honest man and it
ain't uh
i think it's got anything to do just
with the game that's just life
because i really love them you know i
think that's that's the
that's the roughest thing is not having
them there every day and you know
every time they uh every time they come
and they get ready to leave it i think
that reality sinks back in
you know what i mean does that make
sense i think that i think that reality
starts to settle back in that hey
they're going home that this is how it
is no i'm divorced and i have two
daughters
so you know you know how it goes you
know just with kids and not having them
there
every day you know what i'm saying it's
and people have to understand you know
you harp on fathers and things like that
you have to understand
nobody's going to be there 100 not
living in the house
but these women want you to be 100
entertaining everything that they got
going on it's kind of hard to do i don't
live with you i'm not with you and i'm
speaking this from just a general
standpoint you know
not with you so how the [ __ ] can i be
there 100 percent
you know it'll they'll never be happy
ever
but i think that's something that you
know me and maybe people like yourself
we're willing to accept
it's okay i mean we ought to do your
best
got to do your best love you mark i love
coming to hang out with you man
man we out here in atlanta what's up man
we're going to drink the night of what
here we are
come on man we're going to celebrate
it's a celebration tonight we're going
to be
celebrating a trophy i think you're
going to get man let's do it come on
i'ma let you hold it
all right we're gonna have some fun
today we're gonna have some fun man
thank you for having me once again
thanks for coming by yeah thank you
church we'll do many more of these yes
we will
alright cheers